I think most people would agree Donald
Trump
might be the most divisive presidential
candidate ever even as he continues to
win primaries many are openly comparing
Donald Trump to Adolf Hitler yes it's
pretty common in fact New York's Daily
News ran this front page earlier this
week Trump is Hitler and it doesn't get
much worse than Trump is Hitler so I
asked if he'd come out tonight to
address these comparisons shockingly
he's in town he agreed ladies and
gentlemen here to defend himself is
Adolf Hitler
[Applause]
[Applause]
that's more applause than I expected
Hitler thank you so much for stopping by
tonight and might I add you're the worst
so my understanding is you want to clear
the air because you think you're being
unfavorably compared to Donald Trump
don't get me wrong Conan I agree with a
lot he says a lot like 90% of what he
says I'm like this guy gets it okay but
it's just I'm like the way he says it
it's just it's crass yeah yeah Trump is
very very crass yeah yeah and and even
what kind of person talks about his
penis size on national television yeah
oh yeah I'm so sure Donald Trump has a
big penis I famously have a micropenis
that's what makes a tyrant right yeah no
I Hitler I am very sorry to hear about
your micro penis yeah if I had a gold
filling every time I heard that yeah
oh I can't believe Hitler went there
yeah Wow Hitler anyway we get it we get
it Hitler anyway all these comparisons
to Trump it's like it bums me out you
know any man I mean sometimes I watch
him and I'm like is that how people see
me you know like and I have to be honest
Trump he's starting to make me rethink
some of the things I've done
hmm how am I getting I gotta be made
yeah you're right well thanks for
clearing all that up Hitler oh my
pleasure Andy I'll see you at the beach
house this week you really
[Applause]
that was a pretty saucy sexy Hiller
you